so we edit the comments for YouTube
videos alright for this series well I
mean yeah yeah yeah we do I think I
should've said what right you shouldn't
let me go in let me say something
different but again we can't even if we
can go is like this is the greatest show
I have ever seen these people should get
a race that's messing it up straightaway
[Music]
we are building the chrome dev summit
website yes we are and we are looking
into using push notifications because
we're trying not to be annoying about
them yeah this is one thing that
everyone loves on the web is push
notification haven't ever Esai loves it
yeah stop myself from pitting allowing
like I'm just curiosity he's got the
best of me like my lock screen is full
off my apk I don't know what your
website's about but you have asked me if
I want notifications my answer is always
yes I hated it website for the first
like hey what you're like I don't even
know what for like what are you doing
who approved this maybe the way we
actually think we have a legit use case
namely yeah okay yes we think we do
because we this conference is something
that you can not only have a person but
obviously also watch with livestream
from home which might mean that you're
in a different time zone
yes so what we want to do is that you
can say this session is interesting to
me let me know ten minutes ahead of time
before it's about to start will be
asking for permission at a good time
like like like no defining it was like
well then we would need your permission
to notify you and that seems like a
reasonable time to ask right okay yes I
agree gesture as a context why did I
look into web portion I did and I was
actually kind of scared because I I've
never done it I've never used web push
mmm and I know that back in the day
Google Cloud messaging had like they own
proprietary API and I was like a senator
and it was incompatible with anything
else and I was like I don't want to do
this and I looked into it and it's so
much better it's actually I would say
it's enjoyable now so our documentation
for this still written by montigue aunty
the out-of-date documentation is written
by montigue aunty yes so you should say
this is someone who was on the team like
a few years ago and then he held on us
and he bailed on us but we call him
Montague aunty because what somewhat God
one God if we can we hopefully we can
get like this footage like to display
now from the PWA some in amsterdam 2016
is something like that and it was his
name Matt gaunt but while he was talking
to camera little like the editors just
called him was gone it was I like his
surname so much we'll put it twice so
that was it that was that was how that's
his name gone I think that's why you had
to leave the team Monty
how's it going yes so he was our push
person prefers left and wanted things
changed and we had nobody update the
document a good excellence this is how
we work either way moving on
all right what push good let's let's
talk about this so it is now an open
protocol standardized by the IETF all
the browsers that do implement implement
that specific protocol and that is
pretty much every browser
apart from Safari yes Safari doesn't
have support for web push all right
let's take a look at this so the first
thing that you need for push it
occasions is to have a push handling
your serviceworker and this right just
me to show a notification irrespective
of push but you know you need to show
notification so what do you do is you
just add an event listener for push
excellence and then you know it's
usually good idea to check if you
actually ever got permission from the
user because otherwise the certification
call will throw so it's interesting that
actually I as far as I'm aware every
browser will bundle the push the push
notification permission and the
notification permission like push
permission a notification permission yes
I mean they asked for for subscribe
later on I will get these are will get
asked for permission but it doesn't mean
that you couldn't get a push event
without the user ever having consented
to notifications not in Chrome really
yeah yeah when you subscribe for push
the permission you get there that says
do you want push or not if you say allow
it will give you notification permission
as well exactly it's not gonna push
events without the user ever having been
asked
for permission I think at least if you
triggered by a dev tools for you maybe
but I would say I would say otherwise
I'm pretty sure not instead it doesn't
not in Chrome
get me the bad thing to check before
getting so yes code doesn't throw
because throwing is usually it's
definitely possible that other browsers
may like diverse or even do this like in
a push event but the user has since then
rejected your husband has o removed your
permission to show notifications also I
think a thing that could be happening
not too sure about that
either way I'm just trying to justify
just do a check all right that's all I'm
saying oh sorry so what happens in the
push event you get an event and then the
event has a dot data it works very
similar to a fetch response and then you
can the unmarshal as text jason array
buffer and that's what you get and then
you can use the show notification API to
actually show a notification on the
system on and write the cookies in
notification notification bar on Mac OS
Windows Linux it will be like one of
these on-screen display notifications
are there for couple of seconds there
you go this is pretty much notification
part notification part of web push yeah
yeah that's done but let's talk about
the interesting thing and in this part
we're going to talk about cryptography
cryptography we're not going to talk
about it because one of the golden rules
I think it everybody else's don't roll
your own crypto no it's all like the
spec is out there and it's actually very
readable what how do you need to encrypt
what which data to actually be compared
to the protocol but pretty much every
language has a web push library that
encapsulate all of that logic so out
recommend not doing it yourself use the
libraries and you will actually have a
very pleasant experience of just yeah it
work I remember the days when this was
SPECT and there was a lot of late so the
reason that we use crypto here is it's
for the body of the push message yeah
right well not only that but also just
for being allowed to push in the first
play that the day you can actually prove
the user has granted your permission but
rights are interesting there's multiple
levels here but part of the reason that
it came about was like the the servers
are delivering the push messages but
like you know Chrome maybe eventually
Apple one day or like telefónica who I
think you're certainly used to do the
stuff for Firefox they don't want to see
your
we don't want them to see their own
messages right yes we don't need it in
Iver let's let's reach this mutual
understanding that as we are just
delivering these messages we don't want
any binary blobs and it should stay that
way yes yes we don't want like Michel to
know like we don't want to know that
Michael has a new baby boy or something
like that not not interested yes just we
just want Marshall that data around but
yes we knew it was going to be slightly
more effort for right well that's to be
fair the light which that came out of it
at least sighs but I've been looking at
the web push NPM package which is
written by one of the engines for
Mozilla and it's not only very well
written as and you can actually go and
read the code understand what's going on
but the API is super simple so you can
actually get started quite quickly so
this this is on the Soyuz on the service
it might be sir it could actually be
locally doing development just generate
a prime you need a private key and a
public key right and so there's a
functional this whole process is called
babbit that's the name for the algorithm
I guess it's voluntary
something-something I don't remember
doesn't even matter that much okay so
you need this private key and the public
key the private key is obviously private
so keep it safe the public key you can
pop a size put it in your front-end
anywhere but you will need the private
key on your server site later so make
sure you get it there because that's
what you need to sign with to actually
be able to push the message to the right
slider but the public key will go to the
site to do the decoding yes right I see
I Sam so yeah this is basically the
first call just import the web push
library name to generate your keeper and
that's the first step done so that once
you have those in place we are now on
the client side so in there right I need
to get somehow get my public key so you
could bundle it with your weapon by a
you know web pack or roll-up it could
fetch it from your server as a resource
doesn't really matter you just need to
get in its public so you can just put it
on the Internet nobody cares so public
key is is unique to your site not per
user no it's it's raised to say yeah
right I say us and I mean you can even
have multiple but it doesn't quite make
sense but it's up to you can generate
those it's free okay and so once I have
the public key I will then wait for my
service worker to be already available
and running because that is the one that
takes care of anything it has to do with
that push yeah and
then I can use the push manager property
on the sub soccer to ask for a
subscription it is asking the units to
subscribe basically implies the
permission for notification so this will
pop up the permission dialog and wait
for the little response and actually
user visible only has to be true
currently on the web
we don't allow push notifications that
don't trigger a visual notifications via
station so maybe at some point in the
future that would be possible to do like
a background sync kind of thing
don't know yet for now only with the
permission yeah well one of the things
that we would like to do with like
user-visible kind of well so so here's a
situation say I deliver a push message
to your phone to say you know there's a
new chat message yeah but I know that's
you by your user ID have just checked
that message on your desktop machine
right the ideal thing would be then to
hide the push message just because it's
mobile but then that is no longer user
visible thing because I you know if you
granted the ability to do that then
you've granted the ability to do
invisible work because you were just
your notification hide notification job
done who cares yeah so yeah that's one
of the things where there's a really
good use case and the reason for it we
don't just want to allow notifications
without any visual effect is what well
it would give you the ability to just
send a push message every 10 seconds
attract with the user through the
different IP you're you're running so
smoke in the background why not do so
basically privacy battery in all kinds
of all of that all the bad things yeah
there's always that web has to think
about these things
yes and Betty what a pattern that's like
okay I'm gonna promise I'm always gonna
show notification and if you don't
chrome will show one for you so it's not
like you can get around it and and we
provide our public key so that way we
can use a private key to sign things and
the clients I can check it actually came
from us and this is how it's also going
to decode the body
yeah right right right right so then
then we get back once the user actually
presses allow you can show me that if
you go you can send in your pusher
vacations we will get a subscription and
I find this interesting because there's
actually very little data in there there
is the endpoint
that the server-side later on we'll use
to send push notifications out and so in
chrome it will be firebase club
messaging Google API SOCOM in Mozilla it
will be Oh mozilla server I'm pretty
sure and Jim is gonna use a Microsoft
server I'm not sure about that and
sahari as he said it doesn't have it yet
there's an expiration time and there's
the keys which are for the
diffie-hellman handshake but that
doesn't really matter right now but
basically there is no other personal
data in here like it's not like there's
a lot of leakage happening about what
the user is doing or what the
subscribing to it's literally just the
cryptographic keys that are needed to
make this whole thing happen securely
and unlike a zero knowledge kind of
approach okay so we get this back and
now what we do as I said we need to send
this to our server side so one way to do
this would be a fetch where we just post
it to my server list function your
whatever wherever you're running you
need to store that this prescription
thing as a stringify JSON blob on the
server side because you know it should
actually send notification later on and
this and this is going to be unique to
that user so this is something unique to
that user right every you they will get
a different kind of subscription below
that you need rice so now on the server
side we are now at the point where maybe
at some point in future we want to send
a push notification right so we have we
know we have our keys on the server side
we know we have a subscriptions for a
user on the server side so thanks you
need to find all the users that we want
to send something to loop over them and
now do something and again
web push the library makes it quite easy
because you know we get our keys we get
our subscription for that particular
user yeah we you set our vapid details
which is the public in the private key
they also demand a contact email or
multiple contact emails in case
something goes wrong you sort of have a
point of contact okay yeah to say make
sense and then you just send a
notification so basically we turn the
push subscription back into a J's blob
put our body there it can be string it
can be another string a fight JSON
object whatever that will take care of
the inscription and hit that endpoint
from the description and send it to the
user
and that's it and that's it that's all
that's how you do push notifications ups
quite amazed because I literally just
ran through this library wrote it up and
it worked on the first try and that
never happened
so this is the thing because I've I know
bits about the service worker side of
push because we were doing my spec
worker and time but I've never done the
server side of it because it's like it
involves keys it's probably going to be
hardened like I'm not going to touch
that I really need to this it's alright
it's really approachable isn't it so
yeah we now have this on a branch in our
acromial side we still have some some
you know tuning some some edge cases and
stuff to work out how allow people to
unsubscribe if they don't want
notifications anymore because they want
to be nice about this yeah but other
than that up and running we look forward
to spamming everyone with pointless
stuff subscribe to this YouTube channel
we moderate the comments for our YouTube
stuff yes right a couple of episodes ago
there was a guy post the comments and he
was saying I think you could have edited
out the disgusting flatulence noise
that's one where do you see this comment
go did you did you go and listen to what
the actual time some peppers I think it
was me going oh well I thought it was me
but it was one of us doing that yeah it
was just cuz I say you'll have a look at
that and that guy posted 15 comments
really it was 15 of just like variations
on that theme but he was so angry about
that but that is that what has fun
sounds like yes because then you gasping